ready go my house is the house that all
the kids would come to and open up my
pantry and be like I love sugary cereal
growing up shout out to my mom for not
caring enough about me to prevent me
from eating it my favorite ones were
cinnamon toast crunch captain crunch
crunch berries cookie Christmas it's all
about the frosted flakes I was a
deprived kid in the best kind of way I
was not allowed sugary cereals I have
never been more ready to eat cereal in
my life I hope there's some prizes
inside yes with the Cookie Crisp this is
all my favorite one of my go-to there's
a kid see this I feel like will give me
diabetes it looks and smells like
childhood you don't even need to put
milk in this it's so good I've never had
this before in my life because it's
cookies not cookies no it's really good
this is dessert for breakfast you can't
get better than this I don't even taste
any chocolate in this might I venture
that it tastes like cookie flavored
styrofoam which I say lovingly I'm
wishing I thought those would be gross
as an adult because it seems a glass
sugar but honestly it's not that bad we
had to rate this on like scale of one to
ten for childhood cereals this is a
solid nine no I would not give this
above a five is this fruity pebbles no
these are the new tricks it's tricks but
they're not the shapes anymore I've
never had truth have you had pretty
pebbles before mm-hmm alternate title
for this video
Sara tries cereal for the first time see
this was the cereal I wanted to have
this it smells like it just smells like
sugar this joy they're very very fun
looking they look like fun little the
fun little balls from inside out it
tastes so good though sweet heaven Oh
gladly take it I don't taste any of the
flavors it's just like a big ball of
sugar in one cereal after 10 baby I'm
sorry to go back to back tens but these
are at ten I think it's hot for ya
there's my favorite fruit flavors I'm
not as good as the cookie crisps but I'd
give this a five this is an absolute
done this is some end-of-the world [ __ ]
I think I was a little too old for these
by the time they came
but I feel good about it these are your
favorites I want to bathe in these I'm
gonna make a freakin Oreo O's necklace
and weird around my neck whenever I feel
sad I'll just this was like you everyone
Beyonce drop that album and no one knew
that was this this is that of cereal
like it was just like oh [ __ ] this
smells like I need to call my doctor
well we can call them together because
this is gonna be fantastic
hmm see this tastes like what it's
advertised as they honestly don't taste
as good as Wario's just give me the
Oreos I'll trade it for real Oreos this
is a type of cereal you eat and then you
like drink the milk at the end oh yes
yeah never again but the thing is I'd
have to get to the end they had to give
it like a 5 I'll give it a 7
they're fine I just these make me want
to eat actual Oreos instead this is a 9
isn't having me
I would definitely rate with the two I
got two bites and I am fine I think now
my rating for Oreo O's is a six point
seven I would rate it a three I'm sorry
Daniel can I eat the cereal while I give
you my final thought yes this definitely
brought back a lot of childhood memories
for me I'm also a big dry cereal or do
you eat like obvious well now no one's
gonna believe trust you because that's
the sickest thing I've ever heard of no
okay poll in the comments who else likes
a snack on Drive seriously sick of send
yourself to jail I enjoyed it I was very
happy these were a lot of cereals
actually I think this was the first time
I tried most of these cereals so I am
not upset
no but also I am going to get on the
treadmill after this
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]